salut aujourd'hui pour la première fois
sur youtube nous allons faire un grand
concours de calcul mental oui je te jure
que c'est vrai mais le but n'est pas de
faire des calculs très compliqué c'est
aussi de tendre des pièges aux
participants en essayant de brainfuck un
peu leur cerveau nous avons tout 68 à
100 milliards de neurones dans notre
esprit qui sont connectés à peu près
pareil et on va voir s'ils sont vraiment
si performant et si rapide que ça
essayez vous aussi de répondre aux
questions et de faire les calculs et
vous me direz à la fin de la vidéo dans
les commentaires quelle place vous
auriez occupé dans le classement
j'ai pu organiser ce gros concours grâce
à one plus et ça c'est pas un hasard
quand on parle de puissance et de
rapidité de calcul c'est juste les plus
performants si vous avez un one plus
vous savez exactement de quoi je parle
si vous n'en avez pas assez juste le
smartphone le plus rapide du marché ils
offrent des vitesses de démarrage
incroyable il ya 8 gigas de ram et il
est très malin puisqu'il précharge à
l'avance les applications que vous
utilisez le plus c'est qu'il sent que
vous allez utiliser il est très malin en
parlant de puissance il a une batterie
qui permet de faire toute la journée
sans recharger et même aussi un peu le
lendemain enfin ça dépend comment tu
t'en sers mais ça dure longtemps oui je
te jure que ça existe une vraie batterie
de téléphone et surtout avec leur techno
fast charge one plus tu peut recharger
l'équivalent d'une journée de batteries
en menant tambour loïc 30 minutes
bref les vrais connaissent c'est une
dinguerie de performant
[Musique]
nous sommes donc dans l'amphithéâtre de
42 qui est un endroit où vous apprenez
si je dis pas de bêtises la
programmation informatique
ouais on adore cette guerre vous vous
posez peut-être la question de quelques
42 et pourquoi on se retrouve chez eux
c'est une école de programmation
informatique c'est la plus connue mais
c'est surtout avec gratuite
allez sans condition d'âge de limite
d'âge parce qu'il faut quand même avoir
18 ans sans condition de diplôme
allez accessible 24 heures sur 24 7
jours sur 7 c'est un vrai concept et
comme ici à que des technophiles je
savais que ça allait leur plaire
d'essayer de résoudre un peu tous ces
calculs mentaux
et puis potentiellement de gagner à one
+ 6 t oui parce qu'il ya un one
pesticides hague
c'est parti pour le plus gros concours
de calcul mental d internet sous titre
un petit en dessous en fait on n'en sait
rien on n'a pas vérifié
vous aurez le droit de débattre sur la
réponse
et quand je dirai stop c'est vraiment
stoppe tout le monde tourne la zougoise
vers moi et ne bouge plus vous aussi de
l'autre côté de l'écran vous aurez un
temps pour le faire dix secondes
je pense qu'après vous quittez la vidéo
on le sait donc vous aurez 10 secondes
pour essayer de trouver si vous
choisissiez une réponse au hasard parmi
celles ci
quelle serait la probabilité que votre
réponse soit juste
la question est posée vous avez à 25% et
50% ses 60% des 25% chez vous dites moi
vous pouvez commencer à mettre dans les
commentaires dites nous ce que vous
pensez que c'est qu'on commence à les
clients maintenant car ça s'arrête dans
10 9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2 à tant d'égards moi
vos ardoise alors je veux voir si
j'étais si j'ai des bonnes réponses
oh là là je vais pas beaucoup pour
l'instant oui j'en ai une là ok
la bonne réponse la bonne réponse c'est
0% alors oui j'ai décidé de commencer
avec quelque chose d'un peu compliqué
parce que comme il y avait beaucoup de
participants l'amphi était plein à
craquer alors que ce n'était pas prévu
qu'il soit autant il fallait que je
fasse tomber assez rapidement une bonne
partie d'entre eux la réponse n'était
donc pas forcément dans les propositions
parce qu'il y avait 0 % de chances de
probabilité de tomber sur la bonne
réponse parce que ceux qui ont choisi le
25 % de chances forcément il avait 50
portant de chances de tomber dessus
ceux qui ont choisi 50% ou 60% avait eu
25 % de chances de tomber dessus donc
c'était complètement faux il n'y avait
que 0% bon bah peut-être que c'était un
peu trop en fait parce que il ya
personne qui a eu la bonne réponse donc
on a annulé sa et on a dit que c'était
juste pour se chauffer mais pour
récompenser celles et ceux qui avaient
la bonne réponse parce qu'il y en avait
et pourquoi je dis c'est laid c'est
parce que celle il ya beaucoup de filles
qui font de la programmation
informatique ça c'est très très cool eh
bien on leur a offert directement une
place en finale donc si vous aviez la
bonne réponse le 0% et que vous essayez
de faire cette partie là ce concours
imaginez que vous êtes aussi directement
propulsés en finale
vous avez
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs combien font 42 x
24 a remarqué à quel point maintenant
c'est mental je fonde en fait ouais
ouais ouais
pilon le déconcentre un petit peu donc
c'est drôle non -d concentrent eux c'est
de dire tu as vu il est
15h11 enfin 1,5 à 1,6 me 1,2 avant le 1
4 n'en savait pas un calcul mental
attention il va falloir écrire
maintenant car ça fait cinq quatre trois
deux un scope vos ordres aux 9 et les
ardoises c'est comme dans top chef
pierre je te laisse éliminer tous ceux
qui n'ont pas écrit 1008 je vais lama ce
qui reste en course pour l accession
je vais vous conter garder bien la main
quand même levé une quarantaine ok
petite précision alors on a un super
cerveau mais on n'a pas non plus
larchitecture d'un one piece dans notre
tête comment vous auriez pu facilement
calculer 42 x 24 il faut décomposer le
calcul au lieu de faire 24 x 42
directement on va faire d'abord 24 x 20
qu'on va ensuite multiplié par deux et
on s'occupera ensuite de ce qu'on a
oublié alors 24 x 20 ça fait 486 jeu le
multiplie par deux ça fait 960 mais
j'aurais pu faire encore plus simple
pour le multiplier par deux dans ma tête
j'aurais pu faire ça fait mille moins 40
c'est encore plus facile donc ça fait
960 après il reste les deux fois 24 à
calculer ça fait 48 et je rajoute 48 à
960 et j'obtiens mon résultat 2008
c'est possible quand on décompose
[Musique]
voici une histoire à laquelle vous allez
devoir être très attentif s'il y en a
qui sont abonnés à ma chaîne peut-être
que vous connaissez le principe et dans
ces cas-là vous gagnez des points
vis-à-vis des autres et c'est bien
normal si vous êtes abonné les autres
abonnés vous et vous chez vous abonnez
vous vous avez un lien peut être quelque
part bon écoutez bien et ne négliger
aucune information il ya un bus bleu
dont la plaque d'immatriculation et az
de 143,8 l'histoire va commencer
maintenant se servir de ce bus bleu part
il est vide il marqua premier arrêt et
deux personnes montent du continu il
s'arrête et trois personnes montent mais
une personne décembre ils continuent
il s'arrête cette personne monte
il continue s'arrête et deux personnes
montent mais 5 décembre ils continuent
s'arrête et trois personnes descendent
mais une montre il continue il s'arrête
pour le terminus du coup tout le monde
descend du coup vous sentez venir y
avait combien d'arrêt allez-y notez le
sur votre ardoise voyez bien concentré
alors attention vous ne vous et des pas
les uns avec les autres devaient compter
les arènes quoi tu connaissais ça toi
moi j'ai retenu la plaque
d'immatriculation
alors que moi non tu vois pas ce que ça
va être à z de 143,8 excellente question
le terminus est considéré comme étant un
arrêt jura mais ça me changeait rien à
voir donc
est ce que tu es ce que fabien est ce
qu'une droitier des marlins qui ont tué
qui vont écrire cissé qui vont leur
tournée 6 et 9 à a pas mal
ouais ou alors non il faut un écran
digit et il efface juste les digits qui
va s'ouvrir un petit truc comme ça vous
n'avez pas le droit d'écrire votre
réponse sous cette forme là
parce que moi c'est ce que je fais pour
pouvoir faire alors c'était 3 oui bien
sûr oui tout à fait ces terminaux d'un 5
4 3 2 a maintenant vous tendez vers moi
et la bonne réponse c'est celle que je
vois majoritairement je crois donc
c'était 6 la bonne réponse petite
précision comme d'habitude donc il ya
des biens 6 arrêts le problème c'est que
notre cerveau il veut toujours résoudre
des problèmes et il veut toujours
résoudre des choses difficiles is khan
ou est-ce qu'une difficulté ils croient
que c'est ça dont il faut s'occuper et
forcément en faisant ça ils négligent
les choses simples si vous aviez la
bonne réponse il ya trois possibilités
soit vous avez répondu un peu au hasard
soit vous connaissiez un peu le problème
est donc vous avez été très attentifs à
ça soit vous pensiez juste le titre qui
avait un piège et vous avez marqué aussi
les arrêts sur vos doigts pour pouvoir
doubler votre attention parce que c'est
ça la solution quand je dis soyez
attentifs à tous c'est très important
contrairement au one + 6 t qui va être
capable de faire plein plein de calculs
en même temps simultanément nous on peut
pas faire ça donc on va faire les gros
calculs ici et les petits calculs on
peut les déporter sur nos biens et nos
restes 15h02 à jolie devait la main
d'accord clac clac clac clac clac clac
travers je te propose qu'on relance une
ardoise ram et c'est une chance à la 10
e shop
j'adore l'idée mais oui oui car je te
laisse envoyé au hasard une ardoise sur
la personne qui te préfère dans la tête
ouais alors mal at il choisi dans mon
temps à temps ok j'ai trouvé une
solution une solution
le premier qui la prend en fait on fait
pareil pour une personne du fond tu te
mets au fond et tu fais autre chose du
coup n'ont pas pareille chose c'est la
preuve je sais c'est la première
personne
si oui y aura sauvé je vous préviens
mais c'est la première personne qui
vient appuyer sur fond
[Musique]
mon gars j'ai tellement regretter
d'avoir dit ça j'ai vu ma 13e place au
plus il faut pas qu'on pense que nous
faisons attention à trop pris le pouvoir
dans sa tête il a géré les ardoises
magiques
j'ai le pouvoir bon ça va on a réinjecté
trois personnes vous pouvez venir devant
l'adversaire du coup et on va passer au
quatrième calcul
si vous êtes chez vous continuer à
participer au calcul sans vous aider de
votre quelques fessées videmment et si
vous regardez cette vidéo que vous
n'étiez pas encore abonné mais vraiment
abonnez vous il ya une chaîne ont fait
des concours de calculs mentaux tout le
monde il voulait sa bonne foi je rends
c'est un calcul simple c'est vraiment
assez simple mais c'est en rafale hier
je vais enchaîner des choses et je vais
quasiment pas m'arrêter
c'est comme si je te disais un plus un
plus un plus un plus un plus un plus un
moyen plus sain
on est à combien voilà ça va être pareil
est-ce que vous êtes prêts mentalement
les amis j'ai à présent d'être géniaux
de perth
mais tellement tellement je suis je suis
je suis 2 + 5 points 7 + 5 / 9 fois huit
mois 1 + 5 - 11
ne bougez pas je vais le refaire un coup
il n'y a pas de priorité des calculs à
terme les calculs sont bien au fur à
mesure je repars qui attention 2 + 5 x 7
+ 5
il est par 9 voix lui mois 1,5 ou en
compte votre réponse d'un 5 4 3 2 1
maintenant tourner les ardoisières mois
et se passer exactement ce que je
voulais qui se passe alors à temps je
commande un peu les résultats quand même
ne bougez pas regarder vraiment les
ardoises comme ça tout ce qu'ils ont
mais 42 vous pouvez déjà baissé leurs
doigts s'est passé
c'est plus pervers que ça j'ai fait un
calcul qui amène à 41 comme ça quand tu
arrives à la fin du calcul tu dis mais
d'angoulême à 42 c'est sûr mais non
c'était vraiment 41 ok 41 c'est bon tout
135 c'est toi tu te dis j'y vais bon
alors non il n'y avait pas de grandes
difficultés dedans il fallait juste
faire preuve de beaucoup d'attention de
beaucoup de concentration pour pas se
faire larguer parce qu'on veut pas
revenir en arrière
et puis après il suffisait d'appliquer
des petites astuces de calcul mental
parce que forcément la fin était 41
comme leur école s'appelait 42 je
voulais qu'ils à un vrai doute arriver à
41 ans résidant à temps il a voulu nous
faire un jo qui nous met 40 de
maintenance était vraiment 41 quand on
fait du calcul mental il faut toujours
appliqué un maximum d'astuces par
exemple quand vous arrivez à 11 soit 13
vous n'allez pas calculer on soit 13 en
vrai vous allez faire dix fois très
s'affaissant 30
il reste très une fois que vous avez pas
me vouent leur a coûté 7 et 143 c'est
beaucoup plus simple à faire et
quasiment instantanée dans votre tête de
la même manière si vous devez rajouter 9
à un nombre ne fait pas le calcul ça
sert à rien vous allez simplement
agrémenté a en plus aux dizaines et un
an - aux unités regardez l'âge et 18 si
je rajoute 9 je rajoute un aux dizaines
ça fait 2 et - 1 aux unités ça fait 7 10
8 et 9 27
brett optimiser votre manière de
calculer
moi j'avais prévu qu'à ce stade là on
est plus que 10 personnes regardent ces
marques ea et pierre c'est vrai
attention maintenant on va garder les
dix personnes ayant la bonne réponse et
vous êtes 6 et je me dis l'estimation
était pas si mal et j'aime bien me la
raconter avec ce que je vais vous faire
voir on peut composer des nombres ok y'a
rien à rajouter
vous pouvez utiliser tout ce qu'il ya
sur ce panneau autant de fois que vous
voulez ma question est combien de
nombres on peut faire avec ces quatre
mots 4 10 20 et 100 c'est pas le moment
où tu leur tour maintenant vous allez
écrire vos réponses dans quelques
secondes si vous n'êtes pas sûr mais
c'est quand même quelque chose car s'il
n'ya pas de bonne réponse on va garder
les estimations les plus proches à eau
on lève les fourchette hockey le vélv
élevé il nous restait 6 personnes 1 89
en a 14
on a huit on a 13 on a onze on a huit
gardés les ardeurs du levé déjà il n'ya
pas de bonne réponse alors là oui c'est
un petit peu compliqué c'est pour ça
qu'on fonctionne et par une
approximation c'était les personnes les
plus proches de la réponse j'avais il ne
faut rien rajouté rien du tout même pas
un tir et pain et par notre chip à rien
il y avait douze possibilité 24 80 90
104 110 120 124 180 190 400 105 non là
je déconnais 410 et 420
[Musique]
ok vous êtes plus que 3 les gars est-ce
que les trois derniers peuvent se mettre
bien en premier rang ici on reprend avec
une espèce de mort subite
je pose des questions je laisse un
certain temps je vous dis stop vous
mettez la réponse est au fur et à mesure
on va éliminer
ok si à chaque fois les trois ans faut
ça élimine la question et en en payant
passe à la suivante ça vous mine élimine
pas tous les trois ou à le faire
lentement pour commencer 12 soit 13 à 3
vous retournez les panneaux 1 2 356 à
tulle a pas eu fallait faire deux fois
12 + 12 144 +12 tu as perdu
je suis désolé en vrai c'est comme dans
questions pour un champion du coup tu
vas recevoir une encyclopédie
[Musique]
attention on continue les gains
messieurs 453 divisée par 3 écrivez
votre réponse dans 5 4 3 2 1 vos
panneaux messieurs en 51 oui bien sûr
bien sûr bravo bravo bravo
attention celle-ci vous avez quatre
secondes ses terres je vais dire la
question et je fais le décompte direct
derrière je n'écoutais pas je vais faire
le décompte comme ça pour pas vous
déconcentrer ok je faire allez je vais
partir de simples messieurs
interrogé un portable qui c'est on est
plus amer d' énormes et s'éloigne plus
qui t'appelle messieurs vous souvenez de
ce que j'ai à me dire je vais faire le
décompte très rapidement et à la fin tu
as que vous devez mettre votre résultat
ma question est la suivante combien fait
1 millions / 20 votre ardoise s'il vous
plaît à alain gagnon on a un gagnant on
na kim et 50000 et l'autre 500 mille
feux stop
il a mis cinquante mille mais il a mis
son espace n'importe où
et quand comme moi j'ai pas mû oktar je
suis dégoûté tu sais ce que ça me
rappelle ça me rappelle quand il y avait
une miss univers et on l'avait
couronnées et de seconde à prendre a
fait un nom à temps et on l'avait donné
je suis désolé si tu perds mais c'est
terrible question suivante
attention ceux qui ont regardé ma vidéo
sur les calculs jusqu'à 100 x 100 de
tête vidéo qui s'affichent au dessus de
moi que vous avez déjà le faire de tête
ceux qui n'ont pas regardé la vidéo est
bien dommage
attention c'est parti vous avez 20
secondes 18 mois 46 tendez vos ardoise
s'il vous plaît céder quoi 18h46
d'accord dhabi quoi
848 d'accord et toi tu amis et ils
tremblent messieurs vos réponses sont
complètement fausses un précieux quelle
est la racine carrée de 1764 10 9 8 7 6
5 4 3 2 à stop proposer quelque chose on
a 42 d'un côté 32,2 l'autre témoin après
il va me dire mais c'était un 4 c'est
bien 42 à tonnerre d'applaudissements de
médailles deux d'argent des jeunes c'est
pourquoi nos romans roland est un prénom
c'est corentin bravo
là je vais pas revenir sur tous les
petits calculs hyper rapide vous avez vu
des fois il y avait des petits pièges
par exemple 1 millions / 50 beaucoup de
zéros à manipuler surtout qu'en plus
c'était divisé par 20 ce qui n'a rien à
voir non j'aurais juste de revenir sur
la soustraction on en fait de moins en
moins des gros soustraction alors qu'il
ya une méthode très simple pour le faire
c'est ce qu'on appelle le calcul de la
boulangère non pas tant que ça mais par
contre va compter comme elle quand elle
te rend la monnaie
oui ben voilà ben pour le calcul 2010
neuf mois 1982 ça donne 37 c'est l'âge
que je vais avoir cette année je sais
pour le calcul et on va faire comme la
boulangère hommes à partir du plus petit
nombre
c'est à dire chez la boulangère c'est le
prix que tu dois payer là en
l'occurrence et 1982 et après on va
monter comme ça jusqu'à 2019 1982 plus
suite nous fait 1990 plus dit ça nous
fait 2000 et dans la tête on sait qu'on
est à 18 on a 18 comme ça de retenue de
et puis après ben on peut rajouter
directement 19 mois je vais rajouter 20
parce que c'est plus simple comme on
disait tout à l'heure pour simplifier
donc plus 20 ça fait 38 mais quand même
moins ça fait 37
c'est comme ça qu'on fait par exemple
qu'on achète une baguette à 6 euros 47
eh bien elle fait donc trois ça nous
fait 6 50 et 50 ça nous fait 7 et 3 ça
nous fait bien 3,50 c'est très cher non
salohy comme baguette mais en fait j'ai
l'impression que quand tu me prendre la
monnaie pour acheter le pain tu te fous
de ma gueule
alors comment est ce que vous
ned sorti j'ai hâte de savoir dites le
moi dans les commentaires vraiment
laïque et la vidéo d'ailleurs si ce
concept vous a plu merci à 42 de nous
avoir accueillis et aux étudiants de 42
d'avoir participé bravo aux gagnants
et surtout merci à one plus d'avoir
rendu cette vidéo possible il m'a envoyé
le one + 6 t il ya quelques temps et
pour la première fois quand même depuis
des années eh bien j'ai changé de marque
je suis passé chez eux ils m'ont
convaincu vraiment donc je suis très
heureux de le faire avec eux vous avez
un lien évidemment dans la description
aller visiter allez découvrir ce
smartphone c'est une belle grid
performance je vous le dis jamais mais
n'hésitez pas à partager cette vidéo
pour voir un petit peu les performances
des gens dans votre entourage et voir où
est ce qu'ils vont se faire avoir ou pas
vous pouvez vous abonner à ma chaîne en
cliquant ici à ma chaîne secondaire quoi
il une chaîne secondaire oui loïc à une
chaîne secondaire en cliquant là ici la
vidéo de la semaine dernière ici une
autre vidéo sur les astuces de calculs
justement à très bientôt ciao